New Year's resolutions.
Oh, hi!
I'm Teri and in this segment, we're going to be talking about how to make a New Year's resolution.
It's about that time of year again, folks,...
...and we've got to start making our New Year's resolution lists.
So what I recommend, first of all, is take out a piece of paper and a pen...
...and write down all the things that you would like to change about yourself or your situation.
So whether it be a financial goal, a physical goal, a spiritual goal, choose one thing.
Or you could choose one from each category.
The big thing is you don't wanna have ten or fifteen goals.
It's a little overwhelming.
Get through one goal and then focus on the next one.
So, write out a list of all the different things that you wanna change...
...and choose one and make sure it's realistic.
That's the number one thing I can tell you: be realistic.
If you want to lose weight, don't go with an unrealistic amount,...
...you know, maybe say, "I want to lose ten pounds" or "I want to lose twenty pounds."
And start with that goal and then go from there.
You want to break down your objectives.
So let's say eventually you want to lose a hundred pounds.
Start with ten or twenty so that you can see your progress happening.
Also, do something that's going to make you feel good,...
...something that you can imagine would make your life better.
So, those are a couple of hints.
You know, if it's a bad habit or something,...
...choose something that you want to just get rid of in your life...
...and you will feel so good about making this resolution that it'll have to stick.
And that's how you make a New Year's resolution.